Hey Thoughty2 here.
This tower of testosterone is Danish man-beast
Peter Freuchen.
He’s like a cross between Hodor and James
Bond, “The name’s Hodor, Hodor Hodor”.
During his life Peter Freuchen was an arctic
explorer, doctor, anthropologist, zoologist,
journalist, actor, author, and generally just
a badass adventurer.
He is the most interesting man in the world
and I hear he drinks Dos Equis.
In 1906, after studying at university to become
a doctor, Freuchen went on his first of several
arctic expeditions, when he was just 20-years-old.
Peter sailed as far north as he could and
then rode a dogsled 2,000 kilometres north,
across Greenland, in the perishing cold, facing
hunger, frostbite, polar bears and wolves.
It was during this expedition that he discovered
he enjoyed living like an invincible badass
in the nipple-biting cold so much that he
didn’t return from his trip and instead
lived with native Inuit people whom he discovered
in Thule, Greenland.
He lived with the Inuit people for over two
decades, during this time he married one of
their women, gave her two children, killed
a wolf with his bare hands when it attacked
him, established a trading base in Thule and
led seven arctic expeditions.
Because that’s just what you do when you’re
a 6 foot 7 man-titan called Peter Freuchen
and you wear a huge polar bear coat to match
your incredible man-beard.
It’s written that the coat is made from
a polar bear he killed himself, but I think
the bear was so scared of Freuchen that it
sheared itself in front of him and left.
One of Peter’s Expeditions involved trekking
1,000 kilometres across Greenland with a friend
just to prove to him that Greenland is not
separated from the North Pole by a river,
of course he was correct.
The two men nearly died during this trip.
But Freuchen’s closest call was on a later
expedition in 1926.
He got caught in a raging blizzard and took
cover underneath his dogsled.
The snow trapped him inside the sled and formed
a large ice cave around him, he had unwittingly
created his own tomb.
It was so tight and claustrophobic in there
that his beard froze to the ice beneath him,
meaning he had to rip his beard off, just
to turn his head, which of course he did.
Some say the testosterone contained in Peter’s
lost beard have caused the polar ice caps
to melt, out of fear.
So how did Freuchen escape his icy tomb?
You’re not gonna believe this – he fashioned
a shiv out of his own hardened feces and used
it to dig his way out of several metres of
ice.
After escaping Peter discovered he had frostbite
up both his legs and all of his toes had contracted
gangrene.
So he crawled three hours back to base, prised
his frozen socks off then amputated his gangrenous
toes with a pair of pliers and a hammer.
He used no anesthesia and he wasn’t even
slightly pissed.
Peter never drank alcohol because if he ever
got into a bar fight he could potentially
punch a hole in the ozone layer.
In the 1930s he returned to Denmark, wrote
for a newspaper for a while and then wrote
not one but thirty books and several scientific
papers.
He became a prizewinning, bestselling author,
because that’s just what you do when you’re
the most interesting man in the world.
His first wife died of the Spanish Flu in
1921 but he went on to marry a Danish multi-millionaire’s
daughter; her parents ran a margarine business.
They liked Peter so much that they made him
editor-in-chief of a magazine, which is still
in circulation today and is the longest running
Danish magazine in history.
Freuchen also led expeditions to South Africa
and Siberia just for the hell of it, and also
because his prolonged presence in Denmark
and Greenland was causing a shift in the tectonic
plates.
Freuchen then wrote, directed and starred
in several movies.
The most well-known of which is called “Eskimo”;
it went on to win an Oscar.
Nazi film director Leni Riefenstahl attended
the film’s premiere, she was actually Hitler’s
favourite director.
According to witnesses Freuchen lifted her
out of her seat and spun her in circles above
his head whilst laughing his arse off.
Why?
Because spinning Nazis is what Peter Freuchen
does for fun.
Speaking of Nazis.
Peter Freuchen was Jewish and during the war
he was a major figure in the Danish Resistance
movement, hiding refugees and he completely
messed up several Nazi operations.
He angered the Reich so much that they arrested
him and sentenced him to death.
He singlehandedly escaped and fled to Sweden
where he continued to mess up Hitler’s plans
until the end of the war.
Come on, this dude shit-daggered his way out
of an ice coffin, he’s wasn’t going to
let himself be killed by a bunch of Nazis.
Aged 60, Freuchen spent his remaining years
in New York where he “claimed”, I mean
married another woman, who was a major player
at Vogue magazine.
He became best friends with American super
star Mae West and bench pressed Jean Harlow
at a party once.
Finally, he became only the fifth person in
history to answer the $64,000 question, winning
the TV game show “The $64,000 Question”.
A year later he was awarded the Gold Medal
by the International Benjamin Franklin Society
for his “services to mankind in opening
new frontiers.”
He then wrote yet another book and died three
days later in 1956, aged 71.
Some say he never died but was simply hired
to replace God, because he could do a much
better job.
Thanks for watching.